ok
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai fini comme ça excusez moi je me
suis un petit peu emporter mais là ça va
mieux
non parce qu'avant ça l'est pas du tout
j'avais envie de vomir ça allait sortir
soit par la leçon par la semaine de mai
mais là ça va mieux ben oui mais tu fais
peur aussi à mes collègues aussi ils
avaient tous peur moi j'avais peur
bonsoir paul n'en sort pas le goût si
moussa fall bonsoir à savon soir palm
ont fait revoir mon frère paul
bonsoir pas mon serbe oui je suis en
fois quand on veut te voir pôle emploi
ah ouais mais c'est vrai parce que entre
paul qui te fait poireauter 40 minutes
au téléphone et qui après te raccroches
mais folle qui te réclament une fiche de
paie il ya huit ans sinon il te paye pas
dû coûter gagne pas d'argent dit que tu
manges pas paul qui t'envoient des
annonces de métier qui te correspond pas
du tout genre aller travailler en
boucherie où on sécurité de matran jeu
sérieux mais bon ça va jeter quoi je
suis content d'être là enfin tu
m'appeler pour un bien compétences quand
même oui oui mais je suis contente
d'être là parce que cela me permettent
de négocier
un petit peu des choses donc déjà
compétences numéro une ba voila évident
et aussi pas des moindres ça je suis
sincère si l'envié vous pouvez y aller
voilà merci comme justement on va parler
de ma rémunération
j'aimerais donc tu augmentes mon taux
horaire et que tu mets fin à ma juste
valeur merci paul 1 au mieux pardon mon
envie c'est vrai je m'appelle et morpho
jetez pas insulter un allemand c'est mon
nom de famille à la la mais oui je suis
belge
ça se voit pas je suis une femme métisse
moi monsieur oui je suis métisse je suis
wallonne et flamande
je suis né d'un père flamand et d'une
mère wallonne tu es la fille de roméo et
juliette
sauf que dans cette version romeo et
boucher se bourrer la tronche au match
de foot et juliette est une stressé de
la vie qui travaillent dans le nucléaire
mais a dans cette version à ça finit
bien il meurt pas justice au départ est
tout ouïe et j'ai grandi dans un petit
village très mignon qui s'appelle aux
lois de survie roi en wallonie un
village qui résiste encore et toujours à
l'envahisseur
ouais c'est à peu près ça je sais pas
s'il ya d'une équipe de celle de dôme et
dans ce petit village paisible où on
s'emmerdait avec ses petits toits pierre
son église son petit café ses moustaches
in the village se détournent
complètement de la civilisation là-bas
et le temps s'est comme arrêté aux
années 80 leurs dieux
michel sardou il ya des traditions ô
combien épique comme les course de
baignoires l'essai mais le rituel le
plus folklorique c'est quand on fait
deux fils et un immense bonheur de
paille à travers le village est connu
pour être sur la place dont célébrer la
fin de mars à mai c'est absolument
charmant bon les enfants pleurent un
petit peu beaucoup parce que le machin
tombent en lambeaux et les buts d'un
vide courir à la rivière pour le jeter
avant qu'il ne crame tout le monde mais
c'est absolument charmant mais et comme
dit le belge sommes peu mal ah oui alors
paul le wallon on va en parler ça situe
peut le noter dans mes compétences
parce qu'on dit oui ça ressemble
français non paul oublie tout ce qui se
rapproche du français je vous parle du
pays oui peut-être veut dire non et ou
non bien sûr veut dire oui ça complique
les actualisations la wii mais le belge
est très spécial humour aussi un humour
très terre à terre
ben en fait il est décédé
il avait trop bu il a eu un accident moi
c'est qu'il avait soif
voilà humour qui se ressent aussi dans
l'administration mais ça je pense que
c'est comment à tous les pays c'est ce
qui nous rapproche alors sache que paul
en belgique tu t'appelles le forem donc
le forum pour l'emploi et je vais te
relire un courrier véridique qui a été
reçue de la part du forem un monsieur
anonymes qui s'appelle maxime voilà
obligé radiation de votre inscription
comme demandeur d'emploi
monsieur le forez re a enregistré votre
inscription comme demandeur d'emploi à
la date du 3 octobre 2018 bourg jusqu'au
là ça va le 30 octobre 2018 vous nous
avait avertis par téléphone de
l'événement
suivant deux points d'essai en
conséquence nous mettons fin à votre
inscription à partir de cette date nous
vous invitons à vous réinscrire comme
demandeurs d'emploi dès que vous êtes à
nouveau disponible pour entrer dans un
parcours de recherche d'emploi
cordialement bon en même temps en
wallonie où l'hymne aux régionales kazim
nationale s'est elle veut la dette haut
du pont billy elle belle petite gueule
pour maître alain d'henry ce qui veut
dire elle m'avait toujours promis une
belle petite cage pour mettre mon canari
ça vole pas très haut un oui mais dans
mon village on est bons vivants c'est
comme chez les hobbits
le belge est généreux très trop généreux
paul tu sais quand je vais chez ma
famille pour un repas comme ça la vie à
tout le monde j'ai peur mon estomac sous
prolifique tellement il est terrorisé
parce qu'on te sers des pensions énorme
et anthony mais non je ne sais pas
qu'est ce qui te mangerais détient pour
les prochains pour la connaissez pas
possible ils ont pas la même notion des
quantités là bas ma marraine au pour
quatre balles et cinq kilos de frites ça
va être juste mais bon je rentre
maintenant sortir toujours accompagné
bien sûr d'un saladier de mayonnaise
comme que tellement ses gratte des gens
bouton qui apparaît sur tâteront genre
c'est trop pour moi j'abandonne ma vie
dit il à pécho temps vous connaissez la
pêche au thon
non non mais pas pêcher le poisson à la
pêche
alors en fait c'est les demies pêche
vous savez de conserver sur lesquels on
met une préparation à base de thon et de
mayonnaise bien sûr c'est très bon si si
si si c'est bon bon après il ya des
variantes comme la poire au surimi mais
je sens que vous l'êtes pas prêt pour ça
donc vous allez me dire mais comment
fait-on pour faire passer toutes cette
bosse mais là bien sûr c'est la boisson
nationale à la barre on voit pas non
c'est trop cher aux gens la bière tu
tombe dedans quand tu es petit et tu
tombes
quand on a trop bu comme un grand c'est
à dire à partir de 8 ans oui c'est le
véritable rituel d'acceptation sociale
ainsi tu bois pas comme nouveauté pas
des nôtres et mon village est vraiment
magique parce que tu as à peine commandé
un verre que tint à 5 est attendu que
sam a finit jamais du coup j'ai réalisé
que j'avais mal compris la bible c'est
pas les pins que jésus multiplient ce n
est pas un petit peu noté humour dans
mon ouïe est encore là aujourd'hui vous
avez que dix minutes - ya une horde x
comme ça au bout
et donc quand la princesse comme moi qui
a grandi dans ce petit village a voulu
faire un spectacle ça suscité diverses
réactions chez ma famille papa oui il
est pas très ressemblants papa j'ai créé
un spectacle et un spectacle comique ça
y est je veux lance avant parce que
comme ça on dirait tracts et drôle
merci
ouais t'as écrit en spectacle est aussi
bien bah non ça va être de la merde oui
moi je moi mon objectif c'est de faire
dernière d'ailleurs tu me l'as toujours
dire moi je suis une pauvre petite mer 2
je vis que pour faire de la merde pour
finir dans le caniveau mais je t'ai
toujours dit d'aller travailler chez
mickey là bas ils ont des cdi tête bien
les peluches les barbies lé nounours tu
vas là-bas façon comédienne c'est pas
vrai lait tiédi cissé 30 ans elle sera
caissière et maintenant je suis là et je
serai caissière quand j'aurai envie
d'être kucher nous mais carriériste va
mais non mais c'est la famille un ils
veulent mon bonheur il me protège il
veut les meilleurs on m'a dit que je
n'ai entendu question rivalisent espère
que son monde c'est la famille ils ont
peur comme on dit comme dit le grand
philosophe denis moon quand on va dans
le nord ont sombré deux fois quand on
arrivait quand on regarde moi je devrai
aussi au milieu mais cela dit je peux
peut-être me venger parce que je sens
une petite peur chez eux là j'ai eu
aussi comme réaction un mot tu vas faire
un spectacle ça parle de nous
voilà c'était une menace pour ce soir
[Musique]
waouh
c'est un bazar après son passage il faut
que je mange ma chambre c'est sa machine
alors emilie prince est eminem
oui comme ma mère comme jeune julie
comme oui voilà et aline oui une petite
actualité et voit donc si vous avez aimé
ce sketch et vous pourrez en voir plein
d'autres à partir du 28 avril au guichet
montparnasse les dimanches à 20h le
spectacle s'appelle il était une mois
[Applaudissements]
richard merci princesse aimée dit rien
papy balle mais merci aussi d'un maire
qui habillés pas voir le 6 mai s'est dit
qu'il admire sur m après la soirée
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tokyo